[Musique]
oui
alors que l'inflation galope alors que
le prix du carburant explosent alors que
les dépenses de logement occupe une
place toujours plus importante dans le
budget des ménages et que pour beaucoup
de nos compatriotes les fins de mois
sont dès le 15 c'est tout pouvoir de
vivre qui nous faut faire droit le spi
qui n'excède que de 200 euros le seuil
de pauvreté la rémunération du travail
aujourd'hui est en panne on ne vit pas
bien avec un smic on survit or jusqu'à
présent votre gouvernement votre
majorité rejette toute avancée sur ce
sujet allez-vous revaloriser le smic
[Musique]
d'abord je veux le rappeler le smic a
augmenté par deux fois en un an du fait
de l'indexation sur l'inflation et sur
le pouvoir d'achat des ménages les plus
modestes au total il aura ainsi été
revalorisée de 3,1 pour cent en un an
alors je vous rejoins sur un point il
n'est pas acceptable que dans certaines
branches les minima conventionnels soit
durablement en dessous du smic et c'est
bien le sens des discussions que j'ai
engagée avec ses branches
[Musique]